all right so today a fun game to play is
would you rather um at least that was a
fun game to play when I was seven and
now I'm playing it again at the age of
37 um for this video the first question
is would I rather do this video or
anything else with my time and the
answer is anything else but we're doing
this CU it's good content what McKenna
are you going to give me the would I
rather yes I am you are okay well let's
just let's get right into I I think
that's was a great intro people are
excited about this idea they'll excited
about the concept
and so let's do it yeah definitely your
best video intro ever so your first
question is would you rather explore the
Arctic or the
rainforest uh I think about this a lot I
think I take you know you think there's
more to discover more to see in the
rainforest but there's something about
just the cold dead Barren miserable dark
gray Wasteland of the Arctic that I find
oddly appealing so I think I'd go with
the Arctic
all right next would be would you rather
be surrounded by spiders or by trans
activists for the rest of your life what
do you mean surrounded like literally
all around you well because you could
argue that I'm already surrounded by
spiders I just can't see them because
there you know like billions and
trillions of spiders in the world so
like what do you mean all around me
imagine tarantula specifically tarantula
well that's more information than you
gave me originally so tarantula so what
I've rather be surrounded by tarantul
and when you say surrounded like are we
talking they're they're crawling all
over me or they just sort of in a priv
do they make contact with me
100% they make contact with you
[Music]
[Applause]
yes and then what are the trans
activists doing they're just following
me around all the time like when I'm
sleeping in my bed they're there mhm and
this is a story about children making
their parents try one
[Music]
bite I'll take the
spiders
okay the next would be would you rather
let everyone have the chance to meet an
alien or be the only one uh for that I
would that's not even anything to think
about I'd be the only one I only want to
be the only one who meets the aliens I
don't trust anybody else uh I don't
trust anybody else to uh make that first
Contact preparing for this my whole life
I've thought a lot about it I know
exactly uh how it would go I
Surrender and I even have it depicted in
a painting so I'd only want it to be me
would you rather be an Avenger or a Jedi
which one of the Avengers I know they
are but which superheroes are the
Avengers is that like Captain America
yeah Spider-Man Transformers are they in
there no th Hawkeye Black Widow ha okayy
Doctor Strange okay and then uh and then
that are Jedi what do Jedi do they don't
have so Jedi they have their little uh
their their their uh
sword and but Jedi can they can move
things with their just the for the power
of their minds can't they isn't that a
thing that Jedi can do I think that's
how the force works well you're the one
who's putting these scenarios in front
of me I need I need all the information
necessary to make these kinds of
important decisions to make uh I guess I
would probably take I mean Thor can is
can basically do everything so he can
fly do it's it's like the Ripoff spider
the Ripoff Superman so I guess I would
take him I think to beat Thor profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things not to like about tech Giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of their
products well the good news is it
doesn't take much for you to take a
stand for less than $7 per month you can
join me and fight back against big Tech
by using expressvpn big tech companies
make all their money by tracking your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that's why I use expressvpn
on all of my devices to make it much
more difficult for them to exploit my
data best part is how easy it is to use
the expressvpn app I just tap one button
on my phone or computer and I turn it on
and it's that simple your data is your
business visit expressvpn.com
walshy use my Link at expressvpn.com
Walsh YT to get three extra months free
that's
expressvpn.com
walshy all right would you rather meet
an ancient ancestor or meet your
descendant who lives to ,000 years from
now so it's kind of a question of would
I rather meet the person who I can blame
for how I turned out or would I want to
meet someone who I'm to blame for how
they turned out in some way I don't want
to know what my descendants 2,000 years
from now what what's going on with them
and I would feel somewhat responsible
for it so I know it's not going to be
good I'll I'll take the ancestor yeah
okay uh would you rather be Ben Shapiro
or Michael
NES well uh that's an easy one because
Ben chapiro is the only one of the two
that as far as we know is even capable
of growing the beard I don't even know
if Michael can I don't think we've ever
seen any
evidence I'm also going to assume that
Ben probably has a higher net worth so
I'm going with
Ben okay that's fair uh would you rather
go fishing and never catch anything or
never go fishing again I already go
fishing and never catch anything so I'll
take that oh okay that's sad um would
you rather only ever eat bad chili or
only ever eat bad
bacon what do you mean only ever eat
like literally that's the only thing I
ever eat in my life I cannot eat
anything else but that no so whenever
you go to eat chili like it's only ever
bad well then I wouldn't eat it but I
wouldn't eat it anymore if it was only
bad so I just would not eat it so what
you're really asking me is what I which
would I rather stop eating right bacon
or chili sure isn't that the
question why do you have to analyze this
well is that the question though because
but that's a difference it's a
difference between every time I go to
eat it it's bad or I can only eat that
food for my whole life okay fine you can
only ever eat that for your whole life
if that's how this is going to be okay
well then obviously I'm going to take
the chili because I think I could
survive that's going to have more
nutrients in it I mean well it depends
also then then ask there's a question
about is this Texas style chili where
it's really just spices and meat is a
Cincinnati chili where you've got even
the uh noodles in there so you got some
carbohydrates you can survive on that
for longer um bacon if you only eat that
you're not going to survive past
probably few weeks I would
think
uh so I guess I'll take the bad
chili
okay would you rather never put your
grocery cart away or always have to use
the urinal right next to someone
else well what do you mean always so if
I walk into the bathroom and there's not
anyone at the urinal I'm not allowed to
go or does someone materialize magically
there's always somebody there could I
just not ever go into a public restroom
ever again then and I just go at home or
is there someone there too we should
have never done this video well I need
all the information I'm trying to do the
the bit but I don't have the information
I need to make the kinds of decisions
that you're asking all the information
is in the question now okay is there
always someone in the bathroom no matter
what bathroom I go to absolutely okay
well then I'm I'll do the grocery cart
one okay God would you rather be
beardless or
bald uh bald
easy okay uh that's it oh is that it all
right well I think I nailed that um I
think in the future uh if we do this
again I'm going to we're going to need
to spell out these scenarios a little
bit more so we have a full picture of
what I'm really choosing because I don't
like to make choices without having all
I like this is an important lesson I
like to be educated on all the scenarios
before I make choices but overall I
think uh I think it worked out pretty
well
okay